i
[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a esta nueva emisión
de los observadores en france24 esta
semana comenzamos en nigeria donde un
conflicto presente durante años amenaza
con degenerar en una guerra religiosa o
civil agricultores ven como ganaderos
llegan a sus tierras con su ganado y
luego vamos a la capital económica de
costa de marfil abiyán donde algunos
barrios todavía no tienen acceso o
satisfactorio al agua corriente
estamos aquí para decirle a sus fulanis
imbéciles que este lugar mismo es para
ellos deben irse de nuestra tierra estas
imágenes son de los agricultores matando
y atacando a las vacas de los ganaderos
fulanis otro nombre para el pueblo opel
en el centro de nigeria se inscriben en
un conflicto que ha durado durante años
principalmente entre los agricultores
que cultivan batatas y papas y los
ganaderos que vienen del norte del país
con su ganado
el hombre que graba es un agricultor y
se molesta al ver que los ganaderos y
sus animales se alimentan de sus
cultivos en su terreno
y muy pronto la situación se pone tensa
por lo general este tipo de incidentes
terminan mal en 2020 murieron más de
2500 agricultores y ganaderos nuestro
observador es un ganadero pero creó una
asociación para tratar de resolver el
conflicto entre estas dos comunidades
ganaderos y agricultores se disputan las
mismas tierras los agricultores
necesitan poder sembrar sus cultivos y
al mismo tiempo los ganaderos están
buscando pastos más verdes donde sus
rebaños puedan alimentarse
el cambio climático la desertificación
son una de las razones que llevan a los
ganaderos a migrar desde el norte en
particular hacia la región central del
cinturón medio lo hacen precisamente con
el objetivo de encontrar pastos para sus
animales
también hay un conflicto con los
agricultores porque los caminos
utilizados por el ganado la mayor parte
del tiempo están bloqueados por las
actividades de cultivo aquí en los
puntos donde hay agua el agua que sirve
para hidratar a los animales es
utilizada durante la estación seca para
los agricultores lo cual crea una fuente
de conflicto adicional entre las dos
comunidades el problema es que también
todo esto se ha politizado y algunos
temas relacionados con diferencias
religiosas ahora son parte del conflicto
la mayoría de los agricultores en
particular en la zona central del norte
son cristianos mientras que el 99% de
los ganaderos son musulmanes
muchas personas han muerto las
comunidades están diezmadas se han
destruido lugares de culturas se han
robado los animales y en algunos casos
los han matado
los agricultores atacan regularmente a
los ganaderos
no los queremos deben irse de nuestra
tierra durante la inversión del
asentamiento en fidel en febrero pasado
murieron montse ganaderos más tarde esa
noche robaron o asesinaron 500 de sus
vacas matamos la mayoría sus vacas que
están muertas pero la violencia también
ocurre entre los ganaderos contra los
agricultores
entonces como ven esta comida estas
patatas las queman perdimos a 12
personas estos enfrentamientos han
causado la muerte de 10.000 personas en
la última década y nuestro observador
nos dice que esta cifra podría agravarse
si la crisis no es manejada
correctamente tiene el potencial para
convertirse en una crisis generalizada
en la cual los cristianos y los
musulmanes se enfrentarán escondiéndose
detrás del velo de la religión pero la
realidad del problema son los desafíos
ambientales son los desafíos sociales
que no han sido manejados correctamente
por eso actualmente nos encontramos en
esta situación
aquí no hay agua
acá no hay agua en abiyán la capital
económica marfileña los habitantes de
las comunas de coco y yukon abobo tienen
problemas recurrentes de acceso al agua
potable en el barrio de abobo te cerca
de 40 hogares se ven obligados a
recolectar agua tarde en la noche como
lo explica nuestro observador por el
problema ocurre desde 2014 en esa época
se hizo la construcción de una nueva
carretera que conectaba a bobote con la
zona del codia angry después de la
construcción de la carretera las casas
empezaron a dejar de recibir agua como
no recibimos agua en nuestras casas
instalamos grifos muy cerca de los
contenedores para recolectar agua el
agua no llega a todo el día solamente
llega entre la una y las cuatro de la
mañana
aparte de eso está la uned oficina
nacional de agua potable que nos
abastecen pueden pasar cada día dos o
cada semana cuando viene en todo el
mundo quiere tratar de obtener agua al
mismo tiempo se vuelve un caos pero
también hay personas que tratan de ganar
dinero y quieren cobrarnos el bidón de
20 litros a 150 francos
efe a la unidad
en realidad no puedo entender que un
problema como éste todavía se mantenga
desde 2014 tenemos una empresa que se
encarga de la distribución del agua este
problema no debería ocurrir en una zona
urbana sobre todo en la ciudad de abiyán
en abril el ministerio de hidráulica
aseguró que el acceso al agua potable no
estaba garantizado en algunas comunas de
abiyán sobre todo a causa de daños
provocados por trabajos viales o por
incidentes técnicos ligados a cortes de
electricidad varios proyectos están en
curso alguno de ellos tiene el objetivo
de mejorar para 2020 interés en acceso
al agua potable en 155 barrios de la
ciudad
y de esta manera llegamos al final de
los observadores por esta semana
recuerde que todos nuestros contactos
aparecen en pantalla donde esperamos sus
fotos y videos para contar la historia
de su lado del lado de la gente